All right, so we know about the first
two ideas in the acronym SPECS,
simplify code and practice kindness.
Let's talk about the third which
is explain why and with examples.
We've found that some of our
best reviewers are folks
who take the time to explain why they
are making the suggestions they are.
They also write code snippets and
provide working examples to
back up their recommendations.
Let me give you an example there.
A student in one of our Python courses
created a class called City and
then added a bunch of instance
variables like name, latitude and
longitude to that class.
This student then cleared a method
called debug inside that class
that printed all of
the instance variables.
The student said that he used this
method for debugging purposes.
Now this code was reviewed by Imran
Nasir who is a Udacity code reviewer.
And we absolutely love what Imran
had to say about this code.
Let's go through it together.
Imran says that you created
a specific method for
printing out the internals
of an instance.
This showed foresight, well done.
So Imran is identifying what
the student did well, that is good.
He goes on to say that you could
also achieve the same thing
with the vars() function.
Now this is interesting.
Imran is pointing
the student to a website.
If we go to that site, we see
the documentation for the function vars.
Now this function returns
the attribute for an instance.
This by the way is exactly what
our student was trying to do with
the function they had
written themselves.
Okay, let's go back to the review.
Imran goes on to say,
I have also created a code snippet for
you to play with.
Here, Imran is using a tool called Gist
which is a simple way
to share code snippets.
When I visit this page,
I see that Imran wrote some code
on how to use the vars function.
Now this is a really helpful tool for
the student to understand
the recommendation Imran is making.
We find that our best
reviewers provide examples to
back up the recommendations
they are making.
Let's see a few more instances of this.